so I just mentioned a broken circle
breakdown and this is also a a really
tragic challenging movie to process
after so what is it about these tragic
stories that I guess kind of draws you
to them I like to learn from my movies
and and I think they do celebrate life
my movies but but but by showing dark
corners of it yeah so but that balance I
find very fascinating so do you need any
kind of decompression time after working
on it or are you able to you know kind
of go home at the end of the day and
live life or is it I don't know I don't
wanna use the term wallowing because I
would agree that there there is an
uplifting quality to both movies and an
empowering quality to them yeah and and
there's a lot of hope and and I mean if
you come to terms with the darkest size
of life then then you can appreciate
that they could be good things even more
so I did need some time after this film
I have to admit but actually working it
was was amazing while we were shooting
with the actors what I mean everything
was it was really amazing
so I it didn't feel happy working on it
you have one heck of a cast here too I
know everyone across the board but
Steven and Timmy definitely that this is
their show here so Kay tell me a little
bit about how you work with them as an
actor's director especially with tons of
very heavy scenes there where I imagine
if you've got to do many many takes it
might be a little tough on them yeah but
I mean that's their job it's what they
love it's really what they love so I
give them what they want and I get what
I want but they're just so gifted you
know what was fascinating was to see how
they actually very approach their role
in a very different way
timmi being young and having all this
energy and and I think his genius also
is his fearlessness he'll try anything
and you'll go this way that way and
sometimes it's like out of this world
good and sometimes it's just not so good
whereas like Steve's more it's more
cerebral he obviously has 40 years of
experience but he will he will let it
come over him he didn't like jump into
this role he just approached it like
very calmly and then and grow into it
how about for you approaching a story
that I was reading a little bit in the
press notes you can't directly relate to
exactly what happened so what why did it
work for you to kind of learn as an
outsider about what this family went
through and then bring your version of
their stories Green I did relate to a
lot of it I have to say yeah I come from
Belgium which is very different than
Northern California but the way the way
David raised Nick the bomb they had I
mean I recognized that that the close
family unity old although I have a kind
of a fractured family but we didn't have
it at some time at some point in my life
so there were a lot of things that I
felt very close to and most probably
because David and Nick are good riders
very beautiful people and wrote very
openly about their experiences so they
allowed me into and it helped that
helped a lot